ah moi je cionne pas si vous voulez
qu'on empêche des gens de travailler ou
qu'on exerce des violences mais je n'ai
pas du tout l'impression que ce soit la
volonté des agriculteurs c'était plus de
d'envoyer un symbole de dire ringis
représente une part du déséquilibre dans
le partage de de la valeur ajoutée
d'ailleurs ringis c'est l'agriculture
française c'est là où vont les produits
français c'est là où s'écoulent les
produits français s'il y a blocage de
ringis s'il y a blocage de l'écoulement
des produits français et les les les
gens iront chercher des produits
ailleurs et ça va nuire à l'agriculture
franise mais Marc fen dit beaucoup de
bêtises il était ministre non mais il
dit beaucoup de bêtises et en
particulier le fait de de faire croire
que BCE qu'on fait une action à ragiss
on va affamer toute la France il faut
que Monsieur fen revienne sur terre ça
va pénaliser l'agriculture française oui
mais c'est c'est ce qui veut dire en en
dernier ressort monsieur fen es ministre
de l'Agriculture il n'a rien vu venir il
est complètement enfermé dans ses
certitudes il n'a pas vu la crise
montere il y a d'abord eu le
retournement des panneaux dans toutes
les commune rurale de France il n'a rien
voulu venir il y a le rassemblement
national dont votre serviteur qui l'a
prévenu sur le fait que son accord avec
les dirigeants de la FNSEA ne tenait pas
et n'était n'était pas suivi pardon par
la base il n'a pas tenu compte de nos
remarques et maintenant il est débordé
par le mouvement et il nous explique
tout ce qu'il a fait est si formidable
qu'il y a la une des plus grosses
révoltes agricoles que notre pays est
connu donc monsieur devrait mais bien
sûr qu' il est complètement débordé
puisqueen fait la logique de la macronie
à savoir ne pas intervenir ne pas
réguler l'économie ne faire que des
demande le mot de Monsieur le maire
depuis des années à la grande
distribution soit pour aider les
consommateurs avec l'hy inflation soit
aujourd'hui pour payer correctement les
salariés les agriculteurs pardon pour
leur travail pareil avec l'UST
l'industrie agroalimentaire qui a des
marges de 40 à 50 % sur ses produits
alors que les paysans n'arrivent pas viv
de leur travail on voit bien que ce
gouvernement est débordé par par pardon
sa propre idéologie à savoir ne jamais
vouloir être l'arbitre dans l'ordre
économique